I'm first one
I was involved in
new media you want to call it that for
about 10 years before I got to Microsoft
and I thought it was time to think about
what was coming next so I name the group
next media so that's not that sort of
we're a small group of about five people
and most of what we do is primarily
developing technologies and products and
services that are about four to six
years down the line but in my spare time
I also spend time doing work related to
education and technology and I have a
long relationship with PBS that goes
back more than a decade with Martha GBH
on a number of projects the question of
all of the things I've been doing is
like I realize it's all related to the
meaning of more because of traditional
video the way you get more is
essentially for video would be longer
and what kinds of things can we do to
enable deeper understanding without
necessarily having it be longer and so
my roots go back I worked at the Voyager
company almost 20 years ago and what we
were doing back in was we were producing
feature films and more to us MIT
letterboxing showing more the picture
providing directors commentaries all
those things that you are pretty
familiar with in terms of DVDs nowadays
but the empower phul thing that I
learned in terms of working with a lot
of directors was the importance of story
and narrative in terms of engaging an
audience and after I left Voyager I went
to another company called continuum when
we started doing more of the cd-roms
that iced also started doing at Voyager
and the first one I did was something
called a passion for art and I think the
problem that I felt with a lot of
cd-roms at that time is that they didn't
really do very much in terms of it was
all about the quantitative nature of the
information and I felt narrative was
really really important and so one of
the things we did with this cd-rom is we
had a whole series of narratives from
the welcome to a tour about dr. Barnes
if you know who he was if you didn't a
gallery to or a thematic tour and his
story of the creation of a singular work
of art and that's sort of the narrative
but underneath the narrative there's
this important missing layer that
traditionally you don't get with video
is which is a contextual exploration
layer and they're in this particular
tighter we had a gallery where you could
sort of get a sense of where the where
the paintings are what rooms they are
how big they are all that sort of
spatial information that you typically
don't get in books or video and we also
had time
Pro based context in terms of showing
the works of art in relation to other
events of the time at the bottom layer
is what we're calling the archives where
we have access to documents and other
things source information so in a sense
the narrative provides a way to engage
you in a particular subject the context
allows you to explore in ways that are
of interest to you and develop mental
models of the information and then
having the source information of the bus
at the bottom allows you to way to
develop sort of invalidate some of your
understanding from that mental model I'd
show up at intrepid then we'd shoot
another hour so that particular
architecture we continued with another
project called Leonardo da Vinci which
is about the Codex Lester if you know
it's one of the in autos notebooks and
I'll go and do this here this is when I
went to corbis
so we tried to do these is always start
with a very brief story to engage you
into the subject
genius
so I go to the home page here Leonardo
like to use organic metaphors for his
ideas so we use the idea of a tree and
so the tree represents Leonardo in his
life the root turned the Renaissance so
these are narratives if you will a
background of the Renaissance the trunk
represents his life is thinking in a
discussion of nature and this is about
the Codex Lester if you know what the
Lester molester is about the earth of
water in the heaven so the tree branches
in the three different branches and
these are contextual narratives and
explorations about those particular
topics and the fruit of the tree is a
gallery of olive Leonardo's work as all
of his paintings and drawings as well as
saw that cluster itself I'll play it
just a tiny bit of what i mean by a
narrative in 1690 by the great power of
gold a painter named giuseppe gazing
performed a marketing monster it
concerned the weight in motion of the
waters and was composed written and
illustrated by the illustrious painter
geometrician Leonardo da Vinci an
inscription identified its former owner
asbury dama della Porta a sculptor who
had died in 15
so that's an example in narrative you
can sort of see what's ahead if you
wanted to jump ahead can always go
anywhere directly within the title to an
exhibit or Maga way but let's go to the
Codex Lester itself anybody here seen
the code of cluster was at american
museum of natural history about eight
years ago just a few and so these are
all the themes that are in the leg in
the lesser if you click on astronomy it
tells you which pages have astronomy you
can go to the individual pages itself
there's insight from our camp who's an
expert on Leonardo at Oxford but you can
look at the page itself now you know he
wrote backwards of course and we can
change that so that you can read Italian
if you know Italian but one of my ideas
was to come up with translator which we
call the coda scope so you can see the
writing in context and you can actually
also turn this into Italian so you can
try and read his writing such as here
you can see Soleil and Luna but when you
when you do look at this you realize
that he writes in first person because
he's having these little intellectual
arguments with himself but this is an
example of sort of interaction and
contextual exploration that you just
can't get in linear former and a book as
well and those are always the kinds of
things that when we did these kinds of
the directive titles that what are we
doing that can't be done better in any
other medium so by 1997-98 I had gone to
Intel and was director of content there
and one of the things that we're going
to do was the first enhanced digital
television broadcast unless and what
they're planning to do was they were
going to send a test pattern of the
Indian from one end of the country to
the other and I said you know that's got
to be the most boring thing that you can
think of and we should do something more
interesting they said well what do you
suggest as well you know I'd I know Ken
Burns is working on Frank Lloyd Wright I
work with Kim before another project let
me call him up and let's see if we can
do something interesting and what we did
was something called the poetry
structure which is about three of the
building seeds in unity temple falling
water in the Guggenheim and in this we
have sort of that same architectural
in terms of there's an introduction
these narrative the stories and then
there's contextual explorations where
you can actually go inside those
buildings and unfortunately don't think
we have enough time to do that either
but we'll keep going and so another
experiment we did was with American
experience in 1998 thinking about how
you can generate related information to
a television broadcast and one of the
things we tried to do was use the closed
caption information and have that drive
links to source information underneath
and that might be an encyclopedia might
be an atlas and might be other thing so
this was an experiment in that and
actually we learned quite a bit from
doing this I think I'll skip it for work
so through the process of these
experiments we've sort of come down to
what I'm calling to the layered
contextual narrative which is bringing
finding out a way to build up taught
links between the narrative layer and
this contextual layer which is
exploration and simulation so that you
can explore a narrative find something
interesting go down deep into the
exploration area through association
find other things you're interested and
come back up into another part of the
narrative related to that or else go
down deeper into source information and
so the first application we were
thinking about doing this with was
thinking about sort of interactive
television and this was the year two
thousand seven years ago and at that
time most of interactive television was
pretty much been strained to set top box
deployments which were fairly small a
number and we really never knew if there
was a big enough audience in terms of
the content whether things were working
or not and so we felt the broadband
internet was really sort of the future
of television and so in collaboration
with Howard Cutler and Mike Sullivan is
part of the front line team we picked
commanding heights which because we
wanted it to be broadband we wanted a
program that would people could get at
that time and pretty much only higher
read and business had broadband
year two thousand and so commanding
heights is a six hour television series
that we streamed entirely online in
terms of three nights and the program
was created from its conception as
something that live on television as
well as live on the web and that the
television essentially would be the
spine of the experience but that would
be just the beginning in terms of its
links to deeper information and the
other constraints about traditional
linear television are you're constrained
by not only the duration of your of the
film but also maintaining continuity of
the narrative arcs that you're trying to
create and what and through the process
of shooting commanding heights they knew
a lot of this was also going to live on
the web so we could tell stories online
in a way that couldn't necessarily be
done within the constraints of even a
six hour television series so this is
commanding heights I'll see if I can
pull it up here so this is it commanding
heights aired in 2002 and it aired
briefly I think during pledge drive at
the end of the year and it has been on
since so this is the site so the number
of components are storyline which is
essentially the entire television
program online there's an interactive
time Atlas individual country reports
and then information about people and
ideas that are brought up in the show so
you can look at the second night and
there are different chapters and call up
say this chapter with Jeffrey Sachs
so you can also go anywhere directly
well let's just skip forward here so
those links are appearing on the left
whenever Soviet power was challenged in
Eastern Europe the response was very
clear in those tanks it was a red army
as a case in Berlin in 1953 budapest in
1956 Prague 1968 the answer was
different warsaw in 1989 solidary 1 99
100 sees the head of the Polish
communist party called mosque out the
direction me so you can go to what was
happening in Poland at that year so this
is the interactive time app where you
see their colors of the country
correspond to the political economic
system at the time as well as different
flashpoint that happens we're talking
about 1989 and the fall of the Berlin
Wall and so you can click and you get a
country report about Germany etc as well
as there is a complete search engine in
here type too fast
which basically calls up every instance
of hyperinflation in the glossary essays
debates country reports interviews and
the story line program as well as other
flash points that you saw on the Atlas
so let's go back to here interesting
thing about this program is that the
television program aired once and
shortly again afterwards but the
audience for commanding heights continue
to grow substantially even it's been
seven years now and it's still I think
now it's in the top 30 but up until I
think even last year was in the top 10
if you do a search for art world economy
in the pic your search engine so I think
one of the interesting learn key
learnings from this is sort of the value
of sort of long tailed distribution of a
program that's on the web if you look at
the cost in terms of the audience that
you reach versus a television show
that's a one-shot versus something
that's an ongoing resource on the web
it's proven to be a very effective way
to do that another big concern we were
first doing this was to taking the
entire television show I'm putting it
out on the web is that kind of
cannibalized video sales I think we
found that that's actually not the true
and really helped generate and support
the cost of the video DVD sales later
after that time I also work at frontline
on a program called age of eight that
aired last summer and very similar
architecture narrative spatial temporal
contextual exploration and
get into that there i'm going to show
quickly the next project we're doing
called the world wide telescope and this
is sort of really gonna zip through
these slides here taking the idea of
narrative and doing it in a very
different way because what we're
creating is we're creating this middle
layer which is sort of the virtual sky
where we're bringing together data from
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey which we
helped make public on something called
sky surfer in 2002 as well as data from
Hubble and the Spitzer Space Telescope
and others into an aggregated virtual
sky and then you can imagine episodes of
life perhaps nova or lectures from
person up Harvard or you know you name
it all of these narratives can be
embedded into the virtual sky with a
little bit of metadata and then
underneath the objects you'll have
access to source data from them as well
I'll show you an attempt that we have
right now and let me go to that so this
represents two and a half people's work
for about three months so far this is
sort of our part-time project what is
this okay so you're looking at the
virtual sky here if you look over to the
left this is a milky way this is not an
image of Milky Way it's actually
procedurally generated from to mass data
which is color rendered correctly and
positionally correct within the sky for
the world coordinate system let's find
something that everybody knows okay so
here is can you turn the lights on under
30 anybody can see this so you're
looking at the Milky Way I mean the Big
Dipper and I will get dark here in a
second okay so here's the the Big Dipper
and we'll go in and
just in an area perhaps below the Big
Dipper and we'll transition from this to
a fuzzy patch in the center and if I
continue to go into a fuzzy patch this
is where make the transition from
ground-based observation to space-based
imagery which is from the Hubble and
what you're looking at is two galaxies
that are actually colliding and Tom
mentioned before about gravitational
aggregation of hydrogen and causing star
formation that's essentially what's
going on right here yeah if you you look
at another part of the area below the
Milky Way here let me find here you
notice that there's seems to be galaxies
everywhere all these little fuzzy
patches or galleries galaxies here's an
interesting one this one is called think
it's m81 so this particular galaxy is
about a hundred thousand light-years and
in the center is a supermassive black
hole about 36 million solar masses and
you can sort of see this what looks like
a very round yellow bubble but if you
look at this in x-ray or infrared
there's quite a bit of activity that
comes outside of the center and if you
look here on the spiral arms this area
here in this area down here what's also
happening there is that's also an area
where gravitational wave compressing the
hydrogen and of course and then all
these objects you can also then connect
to other related information from a
number of other Federation
on the web as well as create imagery for
astronomers want to be able to use on
any particular object so we hope to
release this sometime this fall what the
process that we're in right now is we're
creating a number exemplar narratives
and this is what the UI will look like
when we're done and we'll have
simulations embedded within objects and
the ability to author and create
experiences within this virtual space so
this is our sort of scenario that a kid
might you know engage in a particular
story about astronomy go as deep as they
want go and actually explore because
there is a browse the entire sky behind
any object or connections to other
narratives and links to other sort of
related things as well as have access to
this the source data and the same data
those farmers have so anyway that's it